اجل مجلس القضاء الاعلى جلسته للبيت في
قضيه المحقق في قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت
طارق البيطار قالت وسائل الاعلام لبنانيه
ان تاجيل جاء بعد رفض نصف اعضاء المجلس
عقد الاجتماع بسبب الاجواء المتوتره شعبيه
وقد تصاعدت حده المواجهات بين البيطار
ومدعي عام التمييز غسان عويدات بعد ان قرر
الاخير الاخير عذرا اخلاء سبيل الموقف
فينا في القضيه
في هذه الاثناء اهالي ضحايا في بيروت
اعتصاما امام وزاره العدل لمتابعه تطورات
التحقيقات في انفجار بيروت شهيده محيط قصر
العدل في بيروت مواجهات بين قوات الامن
ومحتاجين ماذا فعل الجيش لارسال تعزيزات
الى محيط وزاره العدل في العاصمه بعد ان
حاول المحتجون اقتحامه مقر الوزاره
من بيروت مراسله العربيه ناهد يوسف اهلا
بك ناهد المعلومات لديك تفضلي
امام قصر العدل قبل حوالي ساعتين غادر
الجميع من هنا وذلك بعد ان يعني خلص هذا
التحرك الى عدم انعقاد المجلس مجلس القضاء
الاعلى الذي كانت العين عليه اليوم لمعرفه
ان كان سيبث بقرار تعيين قادم رديف المحقق
اخر عوضا عن المحقق طارق البيطار وهو ما
كان يرفضه الاهالي ولهذا السبب حضروا الى
هنا وخصوصا وان المعلومات كانت تشير الى
تعيين القاضيه همم
مكان القادر
معروفه بمناسارتها للتيار الوطني الحر
ولذلك كان هذا الرفض طبعا همم يتم تعيينها
او تعيين اي محقق اخر عودا عن القاضي طارق
الاعضاء مجلس القضاء الاعلى ان يشارك بس
عندي نقطه همم بحسب بعض التصريحات لبعض
النواب كان هناك حديث انه في طمنمات انه
لن يكون هناك اي تغيير هل في تاكيدات او
لا
هكذا كانت المعلومات التي كنا حصلنا عليها
من عده مصادر قضائيه ان التوجه كان لي
ازاحه او لتعيين قادم بديل ولهذا كان
الحضور اليوم الكفيف من الاهالي ومن
النواب اعضاء مجلس القضاء الاعلى رفضوا ان
يتم انعقاد هذا الاجتماع بحجه ان حضور
النواب هو تدخل سافر في عمل القضاء وانه
لا يمكن انعقاد هكذا اجتماع مع مع تحت ضغط
الشارع ايضا القاضي غسان عويدات الذي عاده
لم يكن يشارك خصوصا انه كان اعلن سابقا
سنحيه عن هذا الملف بسبب صله القرابه بينه
وبين احد المده عليه وهو نائب غزه زعيتر
كان ايضا حضر الى هنا وكان في نيه الحضور
ودخول والمشاركه في هذا الاجتماع بالتصويت
بالاغلبيه يمكن الوصول الى قرار تنحيه
القاضي بيطار وعلي لم يحصل هذا الاجتماع
كان هناك حاله من الهرج والمرج يمكن القول
همم
اليوم الخارج قصر العدل همم اشتباك او همم
مواجهه بين الاها القوى الامنيه ايضا تعرض
عدد من النواب الى الضرب من قبل مرافقيه
همم وزير العدل وهو الامر المستغرب والذي
يحصل للمره الاولى وكان النائب نائب وضاح
الصادق هو احد النواب الذين تعرضوا للضرب
قال لنا بانه بصدد رفع دعوه على هؤلاء
الذين قاموا بالتعرض له وذلك خلال
اجتماعهم بوزير العدل عندما اجتمع بوزير
العدل ميسون طلب منه التدخل كان يقول بان
هذا الموضوع خارج صلاحياته وانهما طبعا ان
تصل التحقيقات الى خواتيمها ولكنه لن يعلن
ما هي الخطوات التي بصدر اتخاذها ايضا
كانوا اجتمعوا مع رئيس مجلس القضاء الاعلى
سهيل عبود الذي اخبرهم ايضا بانه مع
استمرار التحقيقات ولكنه لم يفضح ان كان
مع بقاء القاضي بيطار ام لا اذن يشير ايضا
ميسون الى انه كانت هناك تصريحات من غسان
عويدات عام التمييز الى عدد من الصحفيين
المعتمدين داخل همم قصر العدل حيث قال
بانه اخلى سبيل انه لو تم اخلاء سبيل همم
الاشخاص الخمسه او الموقوفين الخمسه الذين
كان القاضي بيطار بصدر اقرر اخلاء سبيلهم
فهذا يعني انه اعتراف بقانونيه قرار بقطار
وهو ما لم يحصل وانه ك همم همم كان يعلم
انه ان القاضي بيطار بصدد هكذا قال عبيدات
ان اا بثار كان بصدد اخلاء سبيل الجميع
الموقوفين على دفعات ولذلك طلب باخراج همم
بالافراج عنهم دفعه واحده خصوصا وانهم
امضى مده توقفهم الاحتياطي وقال لو انه اي
مرجع قانوني يقول ان هناك ذره قانونيه
بقرار قطار فانه سيعود عن قراره ويعود الى
سجن الموقوفين ولكن هذا الموضوع غير
قانوني هو طبعا يتحدث عن قرار البيطار
وكان طبعا احاله ايضا اليوم الى التفتيش
القضاء وطلبه من الاجهزه الامنيه عدم تسلم
اي مذكره من القاضي
يوسف شكرا جزيلا لك